WE'RE GOING TO GO HEAD START IS
THE SUBCOMMITTEE WELCOME.
EVERYONE TO REVENUE TAX AB ONE
THIRTY THREE FILE ITEM.
ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBER.
TODAY'S BEEN A BUSY DAY AN
EXCITING DAY WITH CELEBRATING
WOMEN AND IT'S ALSO EXCITING FOR
ME TO PRESENT TO THIS COMMITTEE
AND MY FIRST BILL.
AB ONE THIRTY THREE PROPERTY TAX
POSTPONEMENT POSTPONEMENT
PROGRAM AND I DO WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THIS BILL AND ALSO WE ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
AB ONE THIRTY THREE IS AIMED AT
EXPANDING THE ELIGIBILITY OF THE
PROPERTY TAX POSTPONEMENT
PROGRAM.
HI THIS PROGRAM HAS FUNCTION TO
PROVIDE HOMEOWNERS WHO ARE OVER
THE AGE OF SIXTY TWO BLIND OR
DISABLED WHO CANNOT AFFORD TO
PAY THEIR PROPERTY PROPERTY TAX
WITH MUCH NEEDED ASSISTANCE.
THE STATE WILL PAY ANNUAL
PROPERTY TAXES DIRECTLY TO THE
COUNTY ON BEHALF OF THE
PARTICIPATING HOME OWNERS IF
THEY MEET THE REQUIREMENTS.
AND TO HAVE AN INCOME THAT THEY
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR WELL THIS
PROGRAM HAS BEEN EFFECTIVE
PARTICIPATION IS BEEN QUITE LOW
IN PART DUE TO THIS --
FIGURE THAT HAS BEEN SET FOR THE
ELIGIBILITY --
WHICH IS THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED A YEAR FOR ALL
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE STATE.
AB ONE THIRTY THREE WILL CHANGE
ABILITY TO BE BASED ON
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE LA --
THAT WE HAVE WORKED WITH WITH
THE STATE INCOME LIMITS THAT ARE
PUBLISHED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND HUMAN SERVICES SO
JUST TO GIVE YOU A CONTEXT OF
THAT IN ORANGE COUNTY --
THE ELIGIBILITY WOULD ACTUALLY
BE ABOUT THIRTY OF SIXTY THREE
THOUSAND FOR A FAMILY OF FOUR IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE ARE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS AND ANY HOUSEHOLD
MAKING UNDER THAT.
COUNTIES IDENTIFY SO I'D LEVEL
FOR LOW INCOME IN A TWO PERSON
HOUSEHOLD WOULD QUALIFY.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A MEMBER OF WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
START QUIRK.
BOB JUST TO SAY --
VERY GOOD BILL VERY HAPPY YOU
TOOK THE AMENDMENTS AND AS SOON
AS WE HAVE A QUORUM ALL MOVE THE
BELL.
THANK YOU.
WITH THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA WE DO LIKE TO CLOSE.
I JUST THAT THIS IS ONE OF THE
BILLS THAT I'M PRESENTING THIS
YEAR -- IN
AN ATTEMPT TO WORK WITH THE
HOUSING ISSUES THAT WE SEE --
NOT ONLY IN ORANGE COUNTY BUT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND I KNOW THAT THIS WOULD MAKE
A DIFFERENCE FOR THOSE
HOMEOWNERS.
THANK YOU AND JUST TO CONFIRM
YOUR ACCEPTING THE MOMENT THAT
SETS THE INCOME LIMIT FOR EACH
COUNTY AT THE LOW INCOME LIMIT
FOR TWO PERSON HOUSEHOLD
ANNUALLY PUBLISHED BY EACH CD OR
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND WHICHEVER IS
GREATER.
YES THANK YOU THE RECOMMENDATION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS --
MISSILE WHICH BATTLE.
ARE YOU CAN'T I CAN'T CALL ROLE
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE A QUORUM.
WHEN WE HAVE A ROLE OKAY WE HAVE
A QUORUM HERE WILL CALL THE ROLL
THANK ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH?
THE FOLLOWING BILLS WILL BE
HEARD FOR TESTIMONY ONLY.
AND THE MINISTER FOR POWER I
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIVE AB TWO
ELEVEN WE JUST.
WE JUST GOT A QUORUM SO COME ON
UP AND WE WILL GO HEAD TO CALL
MS MISS WHEN WHEN YOU CALL ROTH
[inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
WROTE [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
MAYES.
LINDA THIS [inaudible]
ONE NORRIS.
BURKE HERE.
REAVIS.
KING [inaudible]
OF COURSE [inaudible]
MADAM.
AN INTERNATIONAL I MOVED THE
QUIRK SILVA BELL.
RIGHT GOOD I MOVED THE PERKS LA
AB ONE THIRTY THREE AND A SECOND
DOCTOR QUIRK.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JUNE.
THE VOTE MISSION IS TO PASS A
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE
HI BURKE AYE BRO.
BRO ARCH YOU.
CHIU AYE GRAY MAY.
MAYES ARI MELINDA'S MULLIN
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS II QUIRK.
HI QUIRK AYE REAVIS CHIANG.
THAT PASSES.
SIX ZERO FILE ITEM FIVE EIGHTY
TWO ELEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM
HERE TODAY AND PROBABLY.
PRESENTING AB TWO ELEVEN WHICH
IS.
A FIVE TWENTY MIND A FIVE TWENTY
NINE PLAN --
IS A FEDERALLY TAX ADVANTAGED
SAVINGS PLAN DESIGNED TO
ENCOURAGE FAMILIES TO SAVE FOR
FUTURE EDUCATION COSTS
CALIFORNIA EXAMS.
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNT EARNINGS
FROM TAXES OF FUNDS ARE
WITHDRAWN FOR QUALIFIED HIGHER
EDUCATION EXPENSES BUT NO
INCENTIVE IS PROVIDED FOR PRO
ACTIVELY ENCOURAGING SAVING IN A
FIVE TWENTY NINE ACCOUNT
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF ONLY SEVEN
STATES.
WITH THE PERSONAL INCOME TAX
THAT DOES NOT OFFER A TAX
INCENTIVE FOR SAVING WITH A FIVE
TWENTY NINE PLAN.
IN A RECENT STATEWIDE SURVEY
FIFTY FOR HIS ANSWERED A FOUR
YEAR COLLEGE DEGREE IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR ECONOMIC AND
FINANCIAL SUCCESS.
IN TODAY'S ECONOMY MAKES SENSE
YET AT OUR CURRENT TRAJECTORY
CALIFORNIA WILL FALL OVER ONE
MILLION DEGREE SHORT OF DEMAND.
IN TWENTY THIRTY ONE OF THE
GREATEST HURDLE STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES FACE WHEN
CONTEMPLATING WHETHER TO PURSUE
HIGHER EDUCATION IS A
SKYROCKETING BROUGHT ROCKETING
COST OF ATTENDANCE THE
LEGISLATURE.
MUST TAKE EVERY STEP POSSIBLE TO
ENSURE COLLEGE SAVINGS.
A IS AT THE FOREFRONT OF EVERY
FAMILIES MINE THIS BILL DOES
THIS BY PROVIDING A TAX
DEDUCTION FOR CONTRIBUTIONS TO A
SCHOLAR SHARE FIVE TWENTY NINE
ACCOUNT.
WITH A LIMIT OF FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR SINGLE FILERS AND
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THOSE
WHO FILE JOINTLY.
SUPPORTING STUDENTS CALLS
JOURNEY IS THE GREATEST
INVESTMENT OUR STATE CAN MAKE IN
LIFTING PEOPLE OUT OF POVERTY
AND SUPPORTING CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC GROWTH.
ADDITIONALLY ACCORDING TO A
SURVEY BY THE UNIVERSITY OF
WASHINGTON AT ST LOUIS KIDS WITH
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS ARE
ALMOST SEVEN TIMES MORE LIKELY
TO ATTEND COLLEGE THAN THOSE
WITHOUT.
AND HAVING A SAVINGS ACCOUNT WAS
A BETTER PREDICTOR OF COLLEGE
ATTENDANCE THAN RACE OR INCOME
LEVEL THIS DEDUCTION SIGNALS ARE
STATES PRIORITY IN PROVIDING A
MEANINGFUL INCENTIVE FOR
FAMILIES TO INVEST IN A CHILD
HIGHER EDUCATION.
DREAMS AND ULTIMATELY
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY I
EXPERIENCE THIS WHEN I WENT TO
COLLEGE --
MY BEST FRIEND WHO WAS A
ROOMMATE ROOMMATE WITH HE HAD A
SAVINGS ACCOUNT THAT HIS PARENTS
A SET UP FOR HIM.
I WASN'T ABLE TO DO THAT I WORK
THREE DIFFERENT JOBS WHILE ALSO
GOING TO SCHOOL FULL TIME THERE
WAS JUST A MAJOR DIFFERENCE AND
NOT NECESSARILY ACADEMIC
ACTIVITY BUT IN ACTUAL
CURRICULAR STUFF AND BEING ABLE
TO FULLY UTILIZE THE ABILITY. TO
BE A FULL TIME STUDENT WHILE
ATTENDING COLLEGE --
AND I THINK THAT HE WAS FAR
BETTER OFFER HAVE THEY ARE LEVEL
SINGLE YEAR AND SINCE THE SIX
I'VE BEEN HERE --
BUT UNTIL WE CAN GET TO A LEVEL
OF FUNDING FOR COST OF COLLEGES
MORE AFFORDABLE WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE MORE TOOLS
FOR STUDENTS TO HAVE ACCESS.
TO FUNDS TO HELP THEM SAVE FOR
COLLEGE BECAUSE IT IS EXPENSIVE
AND THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT IS
TO INCENTIVIZE IT AND THAT
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT THIS
THAT THAT'S WHAT.
THIS BILL DOES AND IT IS A DATE
DEDUCTION WHICH IS DIFFERENT
THAN A TAX INCENTIVE WHICH
PREVIOUS MEASURES HAD --
HAD SOUGHT AND AND I AND I NOTE
THAT IN THE NOW SAYS THERE WERE
SOME RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE
KID A MINUTE COMMITTEE WAS
MAKING IN TERMS OF ADDING A
SUNSET -- AS
WELL AS SOMETHING ELSE AT THE
TOP OF MY HEAD I CAN'T REMEMBER --
MAYBE CAN AFFORD REAR THE
RETROACTIVITY SO I WILL BE MORE
THAN HAPPY.
TO HEAVILY CONSIDER THOSE AND
MAKE AMENDMENTS WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE BUT WITH ME TODAY.
I HAVE CALIFORNIA'S A TREASURE
FROM FEELING A MALL AS WELL AS
LINDA ENGLISH IS A SENIOR
DIRECTOR OF RELATIONSHIPS.
MANAGEMENT AT TI A THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NUMBERS --
I AM HERE TO SUPPORT.
AB TWO ELEVEN AS MANY OF US KNOW
THE STUDENT LOAN DEBT IN THE U.
S. HAS TOP ONE POINT FIVE
TRILLION DOLLARS.
AND THE AVERAGE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT LOAN DEBT IS TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN THIS WE BELIEVE IS A GOOD WAY
TO INCENTIVIZE PARENTS
GRANDPARENTS GODPARENTS.
UNCLES AUNTS TO INVEST IN BY
ALLOWING THEM TO TAKE A TAX
DEDUCTION.
ON THEIR TAX RETURNS AS MANY OF
US KNOW THE TAX REFORM ACT OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN LIMITED.
ASSAULTS STATE AND LOCAL INCOME
TAX A PROPERTY TAX DEDUCTION TO
TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH HAS
IMPACTED MANY OF US PROBABLY
HERE IN THIS ROOM.
AND TO CREATE THAT --
INCENTIVE TO SAVE FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION --
ENSURE THAT THEY DON'T GRADUATE
WITH A HIGH LEVEL OF DEBT HELPS
THEM THE STUDENT I GET ON WITH
THEIR LIFE FASTER BY.
NOT HAVING TO LIVE WITH THEIR
PARENTS BEING ABLE --
TO YOU KNOW TO START SAVING FOR
THEIR FIRST HOME AND PLANNING
FOR THEIR FAMILIES CURRENTLY
THIRTY FOUR STATES AND THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA OFFER THE
RESIDENTS OF FULL OR PARTIAL
STATE TAX DEDUCTION OR CREDIT.
CALIFORNIA IS ONLY ONE OF SEVEN
STATES WITH THE STATE INCOME TAX
IT DOES NOT CURRENTLY PROVIDE A
STATE TAX INCENTIVE FOR
CONTRIBUTIONS. TO THE STATE'S
FIVE TWENTY NINE COLLEGE PLAN SO
WHAT THIS IS DON IS OP MANY OF
THE STATE'S PLANS AND THEY CAN
GIVE THE EXACT NUMBERS.
ARE GOING OUT OF STATE TO
DIFFERENT STATES THAT HAVE
INCENTIVES THAT PERHAPS --
THEIR FINANCIAL ADVISORS ARE
RECEIVING COMMISSIONS AND WHAT
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO DO IS BRING
BACK THE MONEY HERE TO
CALIFORNIA HELP OUR FINANCIAL.
ADVISORS HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO
CAN STATE SO HERE WITHOUT T. I.
A. AS WELL AS A STANDS ITO OF MY
FIVE TWENTY NINE SCHOLARSHIP
PLAN. TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT --
THE PLAN AND IF THE ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT --
GOOD AFTERNOON SO BAD THAT I
HAVE MY BACK TO SOME OF YOU I'M
SORRY ABOUT THAT --
SO I'M HERE WITH TIAA-CREF
TUITION FINANCING INK AND WE ARE
PROUD TO BE THE STATE'S PARTNER
IN ADMINISTRATING IN
ADMINISTERING --
SCHOLAR SHARE FIVE TWO NINE AND
WE SUPPORT THE PASSAGE OF AB.
TWO ELEVEN DISCLOSURES BEEN
RATED ONE OF THE BEST FIVE
TWENTY NINE PLANS IN THE COUNTRY
BY MORNING STAR FOR THE PAST
SEVEN YEARS.
END OF PART OF THE EVALUATION
CRITERIA IS FEES PERFORMANCE AND
THE OVERSIGHT OF THE SCHOLAR
SHARE INVESTMENT BOARD.
SO TODAY WE HAVE --
NEARLY THREE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
THOUSAND FUTURE POST SECONDARY
STUDENTS MOSTLY CALIFORNIANS --
INVESTED OVER EIGHT POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS IN SAVINGS AND
SCHOLARS ARE.
FIVE TWO NINE AND THERE'S A OF
COMMON MISCONCEPTION OUT THERE
THAT FIVE TWENTY NINE PLANS ARE
ONLY FOR THE WEALTHY --
HOWEVER THE MEDIAN SCHOLAR SHARE
ACCOUNT IS JUST UNDER TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
AND 55% OF OUR CURRENT
PARTICIPANTS HAVE A HOUSEHOLD
INCOME UNDER A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND I THINK YOU ALL HAVE AN
INFORMATION PACKET AND THERE'S A
CHART IN HERE.
THAT I'LL JUST REFERENCE WORLD
QUICK.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE THE BILL'S
INTENT IS TO HELP FAMILIES FIND
RESOURCES TO SAVE MORE FOR
COLLEGE --
AND ALTHOUGH --
THE DOLLAR AMOUNT OF SAVINGS
WOULD BE HIGHER FOR THOSE IN
HIGHER INCOMES.
THE IF YOU LOOK AT THE
PERCENTAGE OF INCOME.
THE SAVINGS TO THE TAX IT AS A
PERCENTAGE OF INCOME THE HIGHEST
INDIVIDUALS ARE THE ONES THAT
ARE MAKING BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE
AND A HUNDRED THOUSAND SO THAT
AGAIN THAT CHARGES IN YOUR
PACKET IF YOU'D.
LIKE TO REVIEW THAT.
THANK YOU RHONDA SO IT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN SCHOLAR SHARES
DISTRIBUTED MORE THAN TWO POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS IN
EDUCATION EXPENSES WITH A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF THAT GOING
BACK INTO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
WITH PAYMENTS GOING TO THE UC.
THE CSU AND THE A I CC YOU
MEMBER INSTITUTIONS AND
TECHNICAL SCHOOLS.
SO AGAIN CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF
THE FEW STATES A KIND OF A TAX
DEDUCTION FOR CONTRIBUTIONS INTO
A FIVE TWENTY NINE PLAN.
AND WE BELIEVE A STATE --
TAX INCENTIVES WOULD HAVE A
DIRECT POSITIVE IMPACT ON THE
PROGRAMS.
GROWTH BY ENCOURAGING FAMILIES
TO SAVE MORE --
INCREASE PLAN PARTICIPATION HAS
MULTIPLE BENEFITS OUT NOT ONLY I
WILL GREATER PARTICIPATION HELP
TO DRIVE FEES EVEN LOWER FOR
CURRENT AND PROSPECTIVE.
PARTICIPANTS --
BUT CHILDREN WHO HAVE A FIVE
TWENTY NINE ACCOUNT IN THEIR
NAME ARE SAID TO BE UP TO TEN
ARE SEVEN TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
ATTEND COLLEGE AND OF COURSE
SAVING ALLOWS THEM TO GRADUATE
WITH LESS DEBT.
THANK YOU.
AND JUST TO ADD UPON --
WOODLAND IS ALREADY STATED HERE
SKULL SURE IT'S BEEN AROUND NOW.
FOR NEARLY A YOUR TWENTY I GUESS
YOU CAN SAY --
JUST RECENTLY LAST YEAR WE SAW
OF OVER FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS DISTRIBUTED FOR
QUALIFIED HIGHER EDUCATION
EXPENSES. TO ON MAJORITY OF
SCHOOLS HERE IN IN THE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA MANY WHICH
ARE YOU SEE AND AND CSU CAMPUSES --
AND WE FEEL THAT THE INCREASED
GROWTH IN THE FIVE TO NINE PLAN
WOULD --
COULD RESULT IN OTHER BENEFITS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND IT
THE THE PARTICIPANTS OF THE PLAN --
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO MENTION ONE
THING ON THE THERE'S A REFERENCE
TO A A GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABILITY
OFFICE REPORT.
THAT WAS REFERENCED IN A LETTER
IN THE MAIL SINCE --
IT STATES --
ABOUT -- 3%
OF U. S. FAMILIES USE YOU ARE
USING TO FIVE TWENTY NINE
ACCOUNTS AND YOU KNOW THERE IS
ONE PIECE OF IT THAT --
WASN'T MISLEADING IN THAT THIRD
3% FIGURE QUOTED IN THE REPORT.
INCLUDES A VAST MAJORITY OF
HOUSEHOLDS TO THE TEAM --
SO AMONG THE 25% OF FAMILIES
THAT DO THAT HAVE MINOR CHILDREN
7% HAD A FIGHT WIENER COVERDELL
ACCOUNT IN.
TWENTY TEN ACCORDING TO THE
REPORT ANY TWENTY EIGHTEEN THAT
NUMBER APPROACH IS 15% --
ACCORDING TO THE FIVE TWO NINE
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION THE COLLEGE
SAVINGS FOUNDATION.
SO [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
WHEN IS A?
RENDON WITH CALIFORNIA'S
DEREGULATION.
HELLO ONE SECOND THEIR ENTRY
MICHAEL [inaudible]
WHICH IS [inaudible]
NOT CONNECTED.
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED --
BRENDA BIGGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION --
THIS IS A REFORM YEAR WE'RE
HOPING AND AN EXPANSION YOUR FOR
CAL GRANTS AND FINANCIAL AID AND
THEY'RE ALWAYS BEING EXPECTED
FAMILY CONTRIBUTION AS A
COMPONENT IN COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THESE
PROGRAMS ENABLE STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES TO PREPARE TO COVER
THAT COST OF ATTENDANCE THAT
MEANS A BAR LESS THAT MEANS THAT
ONE POINT FIVE TRILLION NUMBER
GOES UP MUCH LOWER.
AND THAT MEANS THAT WE HAVE LESS
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES THAT FACE
THE POSSIBILITY OF FORECLOSURE
DELAYED HOME STARTS DELETE
FAMILY STARTS AND OTHER NEGATIVE
IMPLICATIONS THAT WE SEE --
COMING FROM THE STUDENT DEBT
BURDENS THAT STOP PEOPLE ARE
FACING TODAY SO THE COMMISSION
IT DOES NOT YET HAVE A POSITION
ON THIS BILL OR ANY BILL WE
HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO TAKE
THEM BUT I DO WANT TO COME HERE
FROM HIGHER EDUCATION
PERSPECTIVE.
PHYLLIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RIVER DOWN DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
FOR THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
CALIFORNIA AND AN INVESTOR AND
SCHOLARS HERE FOR MY SON AND
WE'RE BOTH IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION?
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SAMANTHA
CORPSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S EFFORTS
AS WELL AS MADAME TREASURE WHICH
I TAKE GREAT JOY.
IN SAYING --
ON THIS MEASURE WE HISTORICALLY
OPPOSED --
TAX --
INCENTIVES OF THIS NATURE AB YOU
KNOW IF YOU IF YOU REFLECT ON
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY AND THE
SKYROCKETING COSTS OF CS USING
UC'S IN THE STATE.
I THINK IT WAS A PP I SEE REPORT
SAID THAT THEY'VE TRIPLED OVER
JUST THE LAST TEN YEARS ALONE
AND SO THERE IS A LARGER.
QUESTION TO BE ASKING ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF REDUCING REVENUE TO
THE STATE ON KID FOR FOURTEEN AS
WELL AS FUNDS THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE GO INTO THE CSU WHEN
YOU SEE SYSTEM THAT'S MAKING IT
MORE AFFORDABLE --
WE DO AGREE WITH MUCH OF WHAT
WAS SAID IN THE ANALYSIS IN
PARTICULAR THAT THIS TYPE OF
INCENTIVE REALLY DOES FAVOR
PEOPLE WHO CAN AFFORD TO SAVE I
BELIEVE THE MEDIUM MEDIAN INCOME.
OF THOSE WHO ACTUALLY TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THESE TYPES OF
ACCOUNTS IS AROUND A HUNDRED AND
FORTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR WITH ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WORTH OF
ASSETS AGAIN THAT'S ON MEDIAN
AND AS SOMEONE WHO IS A JUNIOR
IN HIGH SCHOOL --
AND FALLS PRETTY SQUARELY WITHIN
THAT CATEGORY I CAN TELL YOU I
WOULD NOT BE MORE OR LESS
MOTIVATED TO SAVE UNFORTUNATELY.
BASED ON THIS AND AND THE REASON
IS IS THAT AN OVERWHELMING 68%
OF PEOPLE WHO'VE BEEN SURVEYED
ABOUT THEIR LACK OF USE A FIVE
TWENTY NINE ACCOUNTS.
HAVE ACTUALLY SAID THAT THEY
JUST SIMPLY DON'T HAVE THE MONEY
TO SAVE.
AND AND SO THAT BECOMES A HUGE
YOU ABILITY AT C. T. R. A. AN
ADDITION TO A NUMBER OF OUR
MEMBERS IN THE EDUCATION
COMMUNITY HAS ACTUALLY BEEN PART
OF A LARGER COALITION. TO LOOK
AT SOME OF THE DECISIONS HAVE
BEEN MADE IN THE PAST WOULD LOVE
TO ENGAGE YOUR OFFICE IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS.
BECAUSE AGAIN THERE IS A LARGER
CONVERSATION WE HAD ABOUT STATES
PRIORITIES AND HOW DO YOU MAKE
THESE TYPE OF PROGRAMS MORE
SENSIBLE WITHOUT REDUCING YOU
KNOW TO THE TUNE OF FORTY CENTS
ON THE DOLLAR INCOME TOOK I WANT
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE GO TOWARDS.
CATER FOURTEEN PROGRAMS AND SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE OPPOSE BUT
WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE HAVING A
CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM.
ME SEVEN MEMORIES.
WE JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD --
THIS IS --
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN REAL TO
VOTE FOR ME WHEN I WAS A
FINANCIAL ADVISER --
BEFORE I GOT INTO FULL TIME --
POLITICS AND SO I SOLD A LOT OF
THESE A FIVE TWENTY NINE PLANS
AND I BUT ALWAYS TOLL.
OF THE FAMILIES --
THAT START EARLYRIGHT SEE WHAT
THE INTERESTING BIT BEGIN THE
COMPOUND AND LOOKS AT A WEALTHY
FOR ME -- IN
THE COMMUNITY THAT I WAS A
FINANCIAL ADVISER WAS ALWAYS THE
FOLKS THAT COULD GIVE FIFTY OR A
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH THAT I
TRIED. TO TO GET THEM TO DO --
SO THAT'S THE TECHNICAL SIDE OF
ON THE THE THE HUMAN SIDE OF MY
FATHER'S SIX FOOT SIX NO GREW UP
ON A FARM A BIG STRAPPING GUIDE
ONE OF THE ONLY TIMES I'VE EVER
SEEN HIM TEAR UP.
I WAS ABOUT A WEEK BEFORE I WENT
OFF TO COLLEGE AND HE WAS SO
UPSET HE SAID --
CHATHAM SO SORRY I CAN'T HELP
YOU.
WITH YOUR COLLEGE EDUCATION AND
I WAS LIKE THAT OF COURSE I GOT
THIS BUT FOR MY DAD FOR MY
FAMILY PUTTING THAT FIFTY
DOLLARS A MONTH --
HUNDRED HOURS A MONTH OR TWO AND
FIFTY DOLLARS A MONTH THAT THEY
COULD HAVE DONE IT.
AND IF THEY WERE INCENTIVIZE
THEM WITH SOME SORT OF A TAX
BREAK OR TAX DEDUCTION ON THAT
WOULD MADE ALL THE DIFFERENCE --
SO THE ONLY THING IN MORE I WANT
TO SAY IS IAN YOU GOT A COUPLE
BABIES -- IF
YOU HAVEN'T STARTED YET --
MAKE SURE TO START PUT LIKE MY
DAD HAD [inaudible]
ARTICLE.
THOSE WHO HAVE SERVED ON THIS
COMMITTEE WITH ME FOR A LONG
TIME KNOW WHAT I'M GOING TO SAY
THAT I'LL HAVE TO REPEAT IT HERE.
THIS REWARDS THE PEOPLE WITH THE
MOST MONEY.
THE MOST AND THE PEOPLE WITH THE
LEAST MONEY THE LEAST.
PUTTING A THOUSAND DOLLARS IF
YOU'RE MAKING FIFTEEN THOUSAND A
YEAR IN GETTING TWENTY DOLLARS
BACK IS JUST NOT MUCH.
NOW IF WE WERE TO TAKE AND ALL
RIGHT SO WE WERE GIVEN A LIST.
OF THOSE OF US ON THE COMMITTEE
OF WHAT CHIU SHAVE DEPENDING
UPON YOUR INCOME LEVEL --
AND THIS DEDUCTION WOULD BE
WORTH IF YOU SAVED A THOUSAND
DOLLARS TWENTY DOLLARS TO
SOMEBODY YOU MAKE FIFTEEN
THOUSAND A YEAR.
BUT A HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE
DOLLARS TO SOMEBODY MADE A
MILLION AND A HALF WHO FOR
HEAVEN SAKES CAN JUST PAY
TUITION SO.
I WOULD SAY ANYONE FROM THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND OR
MORE. TO GET FRANKLY GET THE
BIGGEST BENEFITS OUT OF THIS
SHOULDN'T EVEN BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THE PROGRAM.
IF I WERE TO DO THIS I WOULD
SORT OF TAKE YOUR CHART OF WHAT
YOUR SAVINGS ARE IN TURN IT
UPSIDE DOWN.
AND I WOULD MATCH DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR SOMEBODY'S MAKING FIFTEEN
THOUSAND I WOULD MATCH.
SOMEBODY'S MAKING A HUNDRED
THOUSAND MAYBE.
I DON'T KNOW I HAVE TO MAKE
SOMETHING UP BUT I KNOW FOR
SOMEBODY AT THE LOW END WE
SHOULD JUST MATCH A DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR IN THAT WOULD.
THAT MIGHT WELL GET SOMEBODY TO
PUT IN A HUNDRED DOLLARS OR
FIFTY DOLLARS A MONTH.
SO IF YOU BRING THIS BACK I
WOULD VERY MUCH SUGGEST YOU
THINK ABOUT REORDERING WHO GETS
THE BENEFITS IN THE PROGRAM AND
AGAIN.
MY COLLEAGUES HERE THIS FROM ME
OVER AND OVER AGAIN BUT THE
DIFFICULTY WITH THE TAX
DEDUCTION.
IS THAT THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE THE
pCREDIT TO MY MIND WOULD MAKE ME
MUCH MORE LIKELY TO VOTE FOR IT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK I
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS AND
ABSOLUTELY SOMETHING THAT WILL
TAKE -- INTO
SERIOUS CONSIDERATION IN OUR
ONLY GOAL HERE IS TO IS TO
INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE. TO TO TO
CONTRIBUTE MONEY I ENTITIES
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS AND IT ISN'T
JUST THE FAMILY OF THE OF THE
CHILD AT OR THAT THE PARENTS OF
THE CHILD'S GRANDPARENTS AS
EVERYBODY ELSE THAT HAS THE
ABILITY TO THROW A LITTLE BIT OF
MONEY AND SO MAYBE A SEVEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR BIRTHDAYS.
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN THE SCHOLARS
ARE SO YOU KNOW I I I I'M A
BELIEVER ENDS IN INCENTIVIZING
PEOPLE TO DO THIS TYPE OF STUFF
WHEN IT COMES TO PROGRAMS ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT --
WHEN IT COMES TO ARE THE FUTURE
OF OUR STATE AND I I THINK THAT
THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
DIFFERENT WAY OF DOING IT AS
OPPOSED TO BILLS HAVE BEEN
INTRODUCED IN THE PAST --
YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT SAYING WE
HAVE ON A PERCENT RIGHT RIGHT
NOW WHAT WE DO THINK THAT THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT A BILL TO MOVE
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WONDERS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO SAY --
I AGREE.
WITH MY COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMAN
QUARTERS TO A CERTAIN EXTENT
DON'T YOU HAVE A RARE.
I THINK NO YOU.
THERE IS TRUTH IN THAT IT HELPS
PEOPLE WHO MAY BE --
WELTON BETTER POSITION TO SAVE --
BUT THAT BUT I STILL THINK WE
OUGHT TO USED TO THAT --
IN THE SAME BREATH I'D LIKE TO
SAY THAT I THINK WE NEED TO FIND
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE
WHO DON'T FALL INTO THAT
CATEGORY TO MAKE THE SAVINGS FOR
THEIR KIDS ALL WHO MAY NOT
QUALIFY FOR GRANTS.
OR FOR SCHOLARSHIPS OR YOU KNOW
WHATEVER ELSE IS AVAILABLE TO
THEM IT'S IT'S A FULL PACKAGE
THIS ISN'T OBVIOUSLY
ENCOMPASSING EVERYTHING SO I
AGREE WITH YOU IT IS KIND OF
FEEL LIKE.
YOU KNOW WELL WHAT ABOUT THE
LITTLE GUY --
SO PERHAPS A BILL IS COMING
FORWARD THAT ADDRESSES THE
LITTLE GUY --
BUT I SEE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO AND AND I'M SUPPORT THAT
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ONE IS
A AND LOOK I I WILL SAY THIS AS
A SEE I I I I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE THAT WE TRY TO BEND OVER
BACKWARDS TO TRY TO PROVIDE AS
MUCH.
ASSISTANCE IN A MUCH --
AVAILABILITY TO THEIR ACCESS TO
RESOURCES AS WE POSSIBLY CAN FOR
THOSE THAT ARE AT THE LOWER
INCOME SPECTRUM --
WHEN IT COMES TO INDIVIDUALS IN
THE STATE --
OBVIOUSLY THOSE ARE AT THE
HIGHER INCOME LEVELS DON'T
REALLY NEED THE HELP BUT THERE'S
A HUGE MIDDLE CLASS AND I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU REMEMBER BUT WE HAD
TO FIGHT GOVERNOR BROWN WHEN IT
CAME TO THE MIDDLE CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP BECAUSE THERE'S A
LARGE MIDDLE CLASS HERE.
WHERE YOU KNOW THEY'RE PERCEIVED
TO BE MAKING A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
MONEY BUT THE MIDDLE CLASS IN
CALIFORNIA IS DIFFERENT IN THE
MIDDLE CLASS?
IN IN ANOTHER STATE --
AND SO THE PEOPLE THAT ARE IS
MAKING A LOT BUT AT THE SAME
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO TO
SEND THEIR KIDS TO SCHOOL OR
GIVE THEM SOME TYPE OF OF THE
ADVANTAGE.
OF A SAVINGS ACCOUNT AND THAT'S
WHAT THIS I BELIEVE WOULD HELP
THEM -- AND
I THINK IS NECESSARY BUT I
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
FEEDBACKS ALL THINGS WE WILL
TAKE OUR EXTREMELY SERIOUSLY
ALONG WITH THE ANALYSIS AND
SUGGESTIONS THAT ARE MADE.
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IN
AGAIN LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH NOT ONLY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BUT ALSO THE OPPOSITION.
THANKS TO HER ROOM THANKS NOT A
CHAIR THIS CALL RUN THANK YOU
BRING THIS FORWARD AS YOU SAID
IT'S BEEN TRIED A COUPLE OF
TIMES --
SUPPORT THOSE EFFORTS WOULD
ACTUALLY SPOKEN THE OFFICE WE'VE
BEEN ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR SO
HAPPY TO SUPPORT ANYWAY I CAN.
AND I SHE LOOKED AT THIS FOR MY
KIDS AND THE ONLY INCENTIVE THEY
OFFER RIGHT NOW SHE CAN PULL IT
OUT TAX FREE BUT I CAN PULL IT
OUT OF SAVINGS ACCOUNT TAX FREE
TOO SO.
I REALLY DIDN'T DO IT BECAUSE
YOU KNOW SUPPOSE ONE OF MY KIDS
WANTS TO BE A CHEF AND I DON'T
GO TO UC SCHOOL OR SOMETHING
THEN.
I'M A LITTLE MORE LIMITED IF I
HAVE A FIVE TWENTY NINE SO
THAT'S WHY THE PURSUIT BUT I
ACTIVELY LOOK TO TRYING TO OPEN
ONE OF THESE FOR BOTH OF THE
CHILDREN SO.
LET ME KNOW I CAN HELP IN GALA
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS.
SO I WOULD ADD SIMPLY ADD THAT I
THINK IT'S CLEAR THAT PEOPLE ALL
ACROSS THE INCOME SPECTRUM
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
ARE STRUGGLING TO PAY FOR
COLLEGE.
STRUGGLING TO REPAY STUDENT THAT
AND WE ABSOLUTELY NEED TO
INCENTIVIZE THIS KIND OF OF
BEHAVIOR AND THIS KIND OF OF
PLANNING.
AND I THINK IT'S REALLY STRIKING
THAT WE ARE WANTING ONLY SEVEN
STATES IN THE COUNTRY THAT
DOESN'T HAVE SOME KIND OF
INCENTIVE PROGRAM AND THAT FEELS
TO ME LIKE A MISSED OPPORTUNITY
SO.
I'M ALSO HAPPY TO BE SUPPORTIVE
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
AND LIMóN [inaudible]
ABSOLUTELY [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
I WILL ALSO BE YEAH.
YES -- THIS --
WERE FOR TESTIMONY ONLY BUT IF
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE --
HE CAN I JUST ANSWER COUPLE --
OF OF QUESTIONS AS WELL ASSEMBLY
MEMBER QUIRK --
I BELIEVE IN THE SAME THING
RIGHT WE SHOULD --
HELP THOSE WHO NEED IT THE MOST --
TAX CREDIT.
BILLS COST A LOT MORE THAN TAX
DEDUCTION BILLS --
BUT I THINK IF WE WANTED TO
LIMIT THE TAX CREDIT TO CERTAIN
INCOME LEVELS THAT MAY BE.
AN OPTION AND WOULD KEEP THE
COST LOWER.
WE ALSO OFFER A MATCHING GRANT
PROGRAM AT SCHOLARSHIP AND I
WOULD LOVE FOR STAND TO TALK
ABOUT IT BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T.
NECESSARILY KNOW ABOUT IT AND TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYES.
AND OTHERS --
SO MEMBER BRO WHEN TALKS TO YOU
I ALWAYS ASK PARENTS WHERE IS
YOUR FIVE TWENTY NINE PLAN AND A
LOT OF THE DON'T KNOW AND THEN
THEY CALL THEIR FINANCIAL
ADVISER IN THERE LIKE.
OH MY GOD MY PLAN IS IN OTHER
STATES AND EVEN PEOPLE WHO HAVE
A FIVE TWENTY NINE DON'T KNOW
WHERE THEIR PLAN IS BUT A LOT OF
IT IS NOT HERE IN THE STATE SO
WE BELIEVE.
WITH A INCENTIVE TWENTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS POTENTIALLY
COULD COME BACK TO THE STATE AND
THAT IS JUST OUT OF STATE MONEY
BUT HOPEFULLY THEY WOULD
TRANSFER IT BACK IN.
AND THEN CONTINUE TO GET THAT
TAX INCENTIVE MOVING FORWARD BUT
IF SANTA ALSO JUST ADD ABOUT THE
MATCHING GRANT PROGRAM BECAUSE
IT IS.
AVAILABLE AT YOUR ELIGIBLE NOW
FOR ANYONE WHO WANTS TO OPEN ONE
WITHOUT THE RETROACTIVITY.
WITHOUT ACTUALLY.
THANK YOU --
YEAH THE THE MATCHING GRANT
PROGRAM THE TREASURE MOM AND
MENTIONED IS --
WHERE WE JUST STARTED OUR SECOND
YEAR OF THE MATCHING GRANT
PROGRAM --
IT'S HAS SPECIFIC ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS ONE OF WHICH IS.
THAT THE AGI FOR THE THE
FAMILIES PARTICIPATING WOULD
HAVE TO BE LESS THAN SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS --
FOLKS THAT CONTRIBUTE OPEN A NEW
ACCOUNT FOR NEW BENEFICIARY.
THEY WILL BE MATCHED DOLLAR FOR
DOLLAR UP TO TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS
FOR THE FOR THE CALENDAR YEAR --
AND THEN THEY'LL GET A BONUS
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS CONTRIBUTION
PLAN.
SO -- THIS
IS THE SECOND YEAR WE'RE DOING
IT WE JUST STARTED AGAIN THIS
FEBRUARY --
AND WE HAVE --
WE GOT SOME GREAT RESULTS LAST
YEAR IN TERMS OF A LOT OF
ACTIVITY WE HOPE --
TO WORK WITH FAMILIES OF CLOSER
THIS YEAR TO GET ANY MORE
FAMILIES OPENING CALVIN SAVINGS.
I WOULD DO A FIVE TWENTY NINE
DAY HERE AT THE CAPITOL
INCENTIVIZE EVERYONE TO COME
DOWN AND OPEN UP YOUR FIVE
TWENTY NINE PLAN.
OKAY THOUGH BECAUSE THAT'S GREAT
TOM.
I DO WANT TO SEE VERY QUICKLY
THAT DOCTOR COURT DOES MAKE THIS
POINT REGULARLY IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND AND IT IS ACTUALLY
A FAIRLY DECENT POINT.
I COMPLETELY SEE WHERE YOU'RE
GOING WITH THIS HOWEVER WE DO
HAVE A SITUATION IN THIS
COMMITTEE WHERE WE SEE A LOT OF
TAX DEDUCTIONS THAT DO NOT
BENEFIT ACTUALLY ARE LOWER
INCOME FAMILIES OR EVEN OUR
MIDDLE INCOME FAMILIES BUT
REALLY ONLY BENEFIT.
OUR WEALTHIEST FAMILIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO THIS
COMMITTEE IS VERY SENSITIVE TO
THAT WE APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
THE MOMENTS YOU HAVE TAKEN.
AND WE APPRECIATE YOU TAKING THE
COMMENTS FROM THOSE HERE TODAY I
WITH THAT IT'S A TEST MONEY ONLY
SO WHEN IT COMES TIME WE WILL
LET YOU KNOW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SOMEONE
MEMBERS PROJECT.
MOVING BACK TO FILE ITEM
[inaudible]
ONE THE OUTLINES.
CALL THE ABSENTEES [inaudible]
GRAY [inaudible]
MULLIN.
MELENDEZ MULLIN DESIGN
[inaudible]
BECAUSE IT [inaudible]
REVERSE.
I WOULD LIKE TO FIGHT A MINOR
ONE I KNOW FIGHT ON FILE ITEM
ONE WE'RE JUST ADDING OUT ON FOR
THOSE WHO ARE.
HI THREE WITH I AM VERY.
ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL
BE MOVING BACK TO FILE ITEM TO
AB.
ONE FIFTY TWO MADAM CHAIR
CALLING.
AB ONE FIFTY TWO IS THE STUDENT
LOAN REPAYMENT [inaudible]
PROGRAM [inaudible]
AND IT'S A STUDENT LOAN
ASSISTANCE ACT.
WHICH WORKS TO ADDRESS THE
COLLEGE DEBT AT THE THAT MAKE IN
OUR GOLDEN STATE.
AS YOU ALREADY KNOW IT IT'S
ALREADY BEEN TESTIFIED.
AVERAGE.
IS ONE FORTY FOUR TRILLION
DOLLARS OF STUDENT DEBT IN THE
UNITED STATES TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND IN CALIFORNIA.
ON CAPITOL HILL --
IN THE PAST FIVE YEARS ONE THIRD
OF EMPLOYERS OF INCREASED
EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS FORCING.
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS BACK
TO SCHOOL TO PURSUE HIGHER
EDUCATION AND KERR.
MORE STUDENT DEBT AB ONE FIFTY
TWO SPECIFICALLY ADDRESSES THE
LOAN EPIDEMIC IN OUR OWN STATE
BY PROVIDING.
A TAX FREE INCENTIVE ON THE
STATE TAX PORTION OF THE STUDENT
LOAN REPAYMENT PLAN CURRENTLY A
STUDENT REPAYMENT PLAN OFFERED
BY AN EMPLOYER.
IS CONSIDERED INCOME OR A
LEAVING THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
GRADUATES FACE IN INTEREST
CHARGES AND INCREASED DEBT.
I TAX FREE INCENTIVE ON THE
STATE TAX PORTION OF THE STUDENT
LOAN REPAYMENT PLAN WILL ASSIST
RECENT GRADUATES IN GETTING OUT
OF DEBT.
AB ONE FIFTY TWO IS SPONSORED BY
THE LOS ANGELES CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
AND I WOULD.
EASILY TAKE ANY AMENDMENTS OR
ANY ADVICE FROM THIS COMMITTEE
OF THIS IS A WORK IN PROGRESS
WE'RE CURRENTLY WAITING FROM
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL FOR
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL ADD A FIVE
YEARS SUNSET ON HIS BILL IN
COMPLIANCE WITH REVENUE WOULD
TAX CODE SECTION. FORTY ONE FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY --
WOULD LIKE YOU TO CONSIDER
SUPPORTING THIS BILL AT SOME
FUTURE TIME.
ADDITIONAL INNOCENCE IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
COR ABOUT HOW THE COMPANY TAX
REFORM ASSOCIATION I WILL THE
LABOR HAVE A SIMILAR COMMITTEE
SIMILAR ON THE BOTTOM.
SO THE WHITE BUT OF HOME.
OKAY AGAIN.
SOME OF THE GOVERNMENT ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION I DON'T WANNA
BELIEVER THE COMMITTEE WITH
SIMILAR POINTS BECAUSE I THINK
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IT AS SORT
OF SIMILAR HYPOTHETICAL QUESTION
IN TERMS OF WHAT'S THE BEST
BENEFIT FOR THE STATE.
I WILL SAY THAT --
IN REGARDS TO THIS SIMILAR TO
THE LAST MEASURE THERE IS AT WE
DO DEEPLY HAVE CONCERNS BOTH IN
REGARDS TO THE REDUCTION OF A
FUNDING TO THE STATE AND OTHER
VITAL PROGRAMS INCLUDING OF
COURSE K. FOURTEEN EDUCATION.
BUT AS WE'RE LOOKING AT WAYS OF
PAYING DOWN STUDENT DEBT --
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FAMILIES TO
PURCHASE COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT
ENCOURAGING OTHERS TO CONSIDER
CAPPING IN ALLOCATING THOSE
AMOUNTS SPECIFICALLY SO NOT JUST
TARGETING THEM TO THE
POPULATIONS WHO NEED THEM THE
MOST BUT ALSO ENSURING THAT.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT JUST AN
UNKNOWN AMOUNT OF FUNDING GOING
OUT EVERY SINGLE YEAR --
BUT WE DO CURRENTLY OPPOSE WOULD
LOVE TO TALK TO YOUR OFFICE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS HERE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NINE THAT WE HAVE
RECOMMENDED --
JUST FOR YOUR JUST OF THE IT'S
ON THE RECORD WE HAVE
RECOMMENDED A FEW.
AMENDMENTS AND WE DO KNOW THAT
WE HAVE SOME COMING FROM --
LET'S COUNSEL WITH THAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU PLEASE.
THE NEXT.
MOVING TO FILE AND THREE AB. ONE
FIFTY THREE ONE FIFTY THREE IT
WOULD.
INCREASE A TAX DEDUCTION FOR
FAMILIES WHO HOST FOREIGN
EXCHANGE STUDENTS ATTEND IN K.
TWELVE PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA.
THESE FAMILIES OPENER HOMES TO
HOUSE THESE STUDENTS AND RECEIVE
COMPENSATION FOR THEIR EFFORTS
BUT THEN DURING TAX SEASON THEIR
BLINDSIDED BY TAXES ON EXTRA
INCOME RECEIVED.
FAMILIES CURRENTLY RECEIVE A
FIFTY DOLLAR TAX DEDUCTION BOTH
FEDERALLY AND ANOTHER FIFTY
DOLLAR TAX DEDUCTION FROM THE
STATE.
PER STUDENT TAKEN IN AB ONE
FIFTY THREE WHAT INSTEAD GIVE A
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR.
TAX DEDUCTION ER STUDENT IN THE
FAMILY HOLES.
THE WORST PART OF THE ADDITIONAL
TAX IS THAT SOME FAMILIES THAT
PARTICIPATE DON'T EVEN KNOW
ABOUT IT.
AND IN THE END OF FAMILY MIGHT
END UP OWING OUT OF POCKET MONEY
UNDER TAX RETURNS WHICH COULD
ULTIMATELY HURT PARTICIPATION OF
THESE FAMILIES --
JUST ANOTHER.
LITTLE THING TO HELP OUT.
FAMILIES THAT WANT TO HOST
STUDENTS.
WHEN THIS IS IN SUPPORT?
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COME ON UP.
GO TO THE TABLE NO.
ME TO TIME.
AS WITH THE CURRENT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION PERHAPS UNLIKE SOME
OF THE OTHER MEASURES HEARD IN
COMMITTEE TODAY WE JUST FLATLY
OPPOSE THIS --
POLICY AND WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
INTERNATIONAL EXCHANGE STUDENTS
HERE SO IRONICALLY THE PROGRAM
ITSELF WOULD REDUCE FUNDS FOR
KIDS --
FOURTEEN FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAMS THAT THE STUDENTS WOULD
ACTUALLY COME HERE TO BENEFIT
FROM -- AT A
TIME WHERE THE STATE IS ACTUALLY
LOOKING AT ADAPTING TO FEDERAL
TAX CONFORMITY EFFORTS --
MULTIPLYING BY TEN THE DEDUCTION
AND MOVING IN OUT OF ALIGNMENT
WITH FEDERAL THAT DEDUCTIONS WE
CONSIDER NOT ONLY TO BE
UNNECESSARY BUT AS A JUST BAD IT
ON ITS FACE AS A MATTER OF
PUBLIC POLICY AND FOR THAT LIKE
I STARK WILL CONTINUE TO OPPOSE.
THANK YOU.
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
SEEING.
NINE THE WE ALSO HAVE
RECOMMENDED.
AMENDMENTS FOR THIS BILL AS WELL.
AND IT IS DEFINITELY ONLY MOVING
ON TO A FILE ITEM FOR AB. ONE
FIFTY FIVE ONE FIFTY FIVE THIS
MAJOR WOULD ALLOW A TAX CREDIT
FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO BUILD A HOME.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF MAKING IT
THEIR PRINCIPAL HOME.
IT'S A PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
HOPES TO ADDRESS THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CRISIS AS WELL AS TO
ENCOURAGE INDIVIDUALS TO BUILD
THEIR OWN HOME.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
CURRENTLY RANKED AMONG THE MOST
EXPENSIVE STATES IN THE NATION I
WILL GO AND ALL THE NUMBERS AND
EVERYTHING BUT WE ALL KNOW IT'S
HARD. TO DO ANY HOUSING IN THIS
STATE NO MATTER HOW RICH OR POOR
YOUR TO GET NEAR --
DUE TO RISING PRICE OF HOMES
THAT CALIFORNIA BECOMES EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS THIS
LEGISLATIVELY.
NOW. FOR AN INDIVIDUAL TO
QUALIFY FOR THIS TAX CREDIT
THEY'RE BUILDING COST OF THE
HOME SHOULD NOT EXCEED THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
FURTHER INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
WOULD HAVE TO MAKE THE HOME
THEIR PRINCIPAL RESIDENCE.
THIS TAX CREDIT WILL BE APPLE
COLD TO A HOME BUILT BETWEEN
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE SO
WE'RE NOT.
MAKING THIS PERMANENT --
IF IT WORKS IT WORKS IF IT
DOESN'T IT DOESN'T.
NOW THE REASON FOR PUTTING THAT
CRY TO PLACES TO MAKE IT CLEAR
TO EVERYONE.
THAT THIS ISN'T TO SUPPORT LARGE
DEVELOPERS ARE LARGE --
HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS BUT RATHER
INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY HAVE A SMALL
PLOT OF LAND.
IN WHO BUILT A HOME ON THAT LAND
FOR THE PURPOSE OF LIVING ON IT
SO IT'S NOT EVEN GRANNY FLATS OR
ANYTHING IT SAYS.
BUILDING YOUR INITIAL HOME--
IT'S NOT GOING TO SOLVE ALL THE
HOUSING PROBLEMS IN OUR STATE
BUT I BELIEVE IT WOULD BE
ANOTHER LITTLE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
THANK YOU A WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION LUNCH
COME TO THE TABLE.
SINCE WE HAVE TECHNICAL ISSUES
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
SOME AT THE CORBIN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE MULTIPLE
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS MEASURE AND
FOR THAT REASON ARE IN
OPPOSITION I THINK.
COMMON TO A LOT OF OTHER BILLS
HER BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE --
AND EXCUSE ME I'M AND APPARENTLY
THE AGE NOW WHERE ANY BIFOCALS --
AB ONE FIVE FIVE IS NOT TARGETED
TO ANY SPECIFIC POPULATION SO
WE'RE CONCERNED THAT REALLY ANY
INDIVIDUAL.
ANYWHERE COULD TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THIS REGARDLESS OF OF THE
NECESSITY OF THAT AND YOU KNOW
IF THIS WAS TARGETED FOR EXAMPLE
TO I THINK IS THE ANALYSIS
POINTED OUT WILD FIRE VICTIMS OR
PEOPLE OF A CERTAIN INCOME.
THAT YOU KNOW THAT MIGHT BE A
DIFFERENT QUESTION AND AND AND
CERTAINLY SERVE A DIFFERENT
PUBLIC POLICY NEED --
I KNOW YOU HAD MENTIONED THAT
YOUR INTENT IS NOT TO COVER
LARGE DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS OR
OTHERWISE BUT WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE DEFINITION
SPECIFICALLY IN REGARDS TO WHAT
IS A BUILDING COSTS THAT
QUALIFIES --
WHAT IS NEW BUILDING MEAN --
IT'S CENTER CAPTION PROJECT
THAT'S MAYBE IN A LARGER
DEVELOPMENT QUALIFY UNDER THIS
MEASURE IT'S FRANKLY UNCLEAR --
IN ADDITION TO THAT --
CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
HAS A NUMBER OF BENEFITS TO
HOMEOWNERS IN PARTICULAR --
AND WE HAVE SEEN OVER THE YEARS
THAT YOU KNOW WHAT TO
CALIFORNIA'S SECOND HOME CREDIT
FOR EXAMPLE.
AS ONE EXAMPLE.
THERE'S NOT NECESSARILY.
A MECHANISM TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO USE THESE
HOMES FOR PRINCIPAL RESIDENCES --
AND CERTAINLY EVEN IF THEY DO
INITIALLY OVER TIME THEY MAY NOT --
AND SO WITH SIGNIFICANT
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PUBIC
POLICY MERIT OF THIS
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE AMBIGUITY
AND DEFINITIONS AS WELL AS THE
SCOPING AND FOR THAT REASON WE
CURRENTLY OPPOSE THINKING.
THANK YOU.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE START WORK.
YES --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I I KNOW YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO THE BEST WITH THESE
THREE BELLS BUT I DO WANT
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
REMARKS MADE BY THE TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION.
AND THEN JUST ADD THE COMMENT I
MADE --
ABOUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON'S
BILL WHICH IS THAT THE BIGGEST
BENEFIT DâN 13% FOR EXAMPLE TO
PEOPLE WHO MAKE.
OVER MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR AND
ALMOST NO BENEFIT. ONE OR 2% FOR
PEOPLE WHO MAY FORTY THOUSAND A
YEAR.
AND SO IN MY MIND THE BENEFIT
HERE IS GOING TO THE PEOPLE WHO
DON'T NEED IT IS SUPPOSED TO THE
PEOPLE WHO NEED IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU FOR COMING
TODAY SO IN OR OUT.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
I WILL MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM.
ONE CALLING THE ABSENTEES MULLIN.
WELL AND I THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED
[inaudible]
THREE YEAH
.
HEY I GOT
[inaudible]
HEY JOHN